Leanne were here at the sundance london
film festival and music festival tell us
about the film that you brought here
it's very special isn't it yes it is
it's a tribute to Kate McGarrigle Rufus
and Martha Wainwright smother it really
showcases her incredible talents and
what a prolific songwriter she was and
also a look into the family of how
they've dealt with the loss since she
passed away so it's very personal film
for everybody you know me too we've all
been very close to it for a long time
now so how did you come to make the film
you know actually Rufus asked me to if I
would do this we had worked together on
the Leonard Cohen film that i made and
which kate was into and so he had asked
me if we would you know make a film and
we did it's been a long road but we're
very happy to be here what were some of
the challenges you faced along the way I
guess with being a personal project it's
one that's very close to your heart
isn't it yeah it was fair it was
incredibly emotional for everybody i
think because of the subject matter and
a very personal film plus i think mixing
a concert film with personal family
story was perhaps the biggest challenge
for me as a filmmaker but you know i
think the concert had that energy with
it too it was very emotional so I think
that hopefully that balance works yeah
tell us about how you went about getting
that balance could you say is a
difficult thing to achieve isn't it it
is used a filmmaker you have to be very
sensitive and also you've got a
celebratory concert and then you have a
very personal issue so I think for me
getting that balance right was the
hardest thing and I found it incredibly
emotional too because it's a very
personal look into the loss of somebody
and I work closely with Rufus and Martha
and so I think it was very emotional for
them but I think also very happy to be
able to do this for Kate you know if and
for her to be here at the sundance
festival it's really an honor so i think
that you know it was worth all the hard
work i hope people like it you know when
they see it but we work very hard tell
us a little bit how you came to discover
Kate's music in the first place
you know I hadn't really listen to any
music until I worked with her on the
Leonard Cohen film and then I started to
listen to the mcgarrigle's and
incredible i mean just such an amazing
songwriter her and anna mcgarrigle I
mean unparalleled for me I mean I know
there are bigger songwriters female some
writers of that generation and era but
for me she's now become the most
prolific I hadn't heard lyrics like this
from a woman writer as well and so I
think I hope that people take that away
from the film like wow these are such
incredible songs which they are and it's
beautiful to have her family singing
them have you been able to go to any of
the events at Sundance and and and so
far it just got here yesterday oh that's
such a shame very disappointed but I
love the 02 it's a bit like Vegas Sun
Dance in Vegas it's very flesh it's
great but no I haven't seen anything I
haven't I haven't even seen the film
with an audience yet so this is my first
time
you